brian austin green may be going through
a public split with wife megan fox but
yesterday his heart was full with their
three sons having breakfast in bed
jessica beal shared this fun shot of
husband justin timberlake giving a lift
to their five-year-old son
silas and wrote in part to the dad who
not only protects and provides but most
importantly
plays gwen stefani posted sweet snaps of
blake shelton and her three sons with
the caption
thank you for helping me raise these
boys hashtag we love you
and we love jennifer lopez honoring not
one but three men in her life
her fiance alex rodriguez her ex mark
anthony
and her dad david last but not least
matt
i bet you macklin made daddy's day extra
special am i right
hey there mac hi rachel rachel
oh father's day is the best day
because father's day know what it's
about
what loving the jobs and all that you
care for them especially on continue
staying in your heart
oh thank you macklin look every day is
father's day especially during
quarantine just ask these hollywood dads
that had no choice
but to mix work and play
you say hi what do you say hey
hi you're so cute
you're so funny yeah i have
my my dance teacher right here oh
my girlfriend i should be the real
teacher
because i've done dance all like every
day
she also wrote me a song yeah
it is your daughter also driving to
tick-tock obsession my daughter is the
leader
she can't walk nowhere in this house
without
that's it kevin's buddy the rock is also
a tick-tock dad
is cnn's chris cuomo
i'm not gonna lie videos with dad gave
me a boost
say bye bye bye
he's actually super smiley like he just
wants attention all day
from bachelor babes to kids crashing
their parents interviews some of the
best moments are seeing how much these
celebrity dads adore their kids
oh speaking of was it snack time
this is my son easton this is isla rose
what what do you mean she lost her too
oh wow mommy put a string around my
juice
then
i'm sorry i'm talking to my son who just
walked in and grabbed the table and it
started shaking
this is hunter guy fieri got the right
idea
putting his son to work as a one-man
production crew so hunter
has produced three shows now my 18 year
old son joshua who just graduated from
high school
who's killing it right now running the
cameras the lights
[Music]
and yeah that's my five-year-old son
macklin working on his hosting skills
am i right do you like dance parties